[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue pour ce nouveau
numéro du 7 8 débat et si les lycéens
franciliens commencer les cours plus
tard le matin cette proposition était
faite par la présidente de la région
valérie pécresse
les adolescents ayant un besoin de
sommeil plus élevé que les adultes cette
mesure serait censé améliorer leur
attention en cours
le ministre de l'éducation nationale
jean michel blanquer s'est dit favorable
à une expérimentation à la rentrée 2010
9 en ile-de-france retardés et les cours
des lycéens est ce une bonne idée
c'est le débat du jour aurélie bourgeon
bonsoir bonsoir
elle vous est administratrice au sein de
la smerep alors pour commencer quelques
mots sur votre société
alors la smerep est avant tout une
mutuelle qui a pendant plus de 40 ans
gérait le régime de sécurité sociale
étudiante qui prend fin à cette année en
début 2019 mais également à créer des
produits mutualistes pour les étudiants
c'est à dire adapté à leur budget et
adaptées aux problématiques qu'ils
rencontrent en tant que jeunes et mais a
également développé un système de
prévention et auprès de populations qui
est particulièrement à risque
et vous avez sorti récemment une étude
complète justement sur le sommeil des
étudiants et des lycéens vous nous en
direz plus dans quelques instants
en face de vous raphaël le goff mon soir
vous êtes co secrétaire au sein du
syndicat enseignant cgt educ'action dans
les yvelines et vous êtes également
professeur de lettres et d'histoire aux
mureaux merci à toutes les deux d'avoir
accepté l'invitation
alors il ya un mois la présidente de la
région ile de france valérie pécresse a
publié ce message sur twitter je demande
à jean michel blanquer aires de lancer à
la rentrée 2010 9 une expérimentation
régionale fait recommencer tous les
cours des lycées à 9 heures ce sera bon
pour les apprentissages et la santé de
nos 500 miliciens et ça dès saturera les
transports raphaël le goff en tant que
professeur quelle a été votre première
réaction quand vous avez lu cette
proposition de valérie pécresse alors
premièrement
je m'étonne vraiment que des dispose des
changements d'organisation pour la
rentrée 2010 9 nous arrive par twitter
c'est une changement d'organisation qui
nous arrive comme ça on à la rentrée
2010 9 on devra déjà gérer une réforme
du bac du bac général du lycée
professionnel des augmentations
d'effectifs dans les collèges avec des
suppressions de postes donc je pense
qu'on aura autre chose à faire que de
gérer le fait qu'on a commencé à 9h
surtout que je ne suis pas vraiment sûrs
et nous ne sommes pas sûrs à la cgt que
cela change grand chose puisque de toute
manière on devra toujours terminer une
heure plus tard on aimerait bien que les
personnels enseignants soient consultés
avant de prendre des décisions et de
faire appel à notre ministre alors on
parlera plus en détails de votre
position sur le sujet l'annnonce de
valérie pécresse s'appuie en fait sur
une étude américaine qui est paru en
décembre dernier dans le magazine
assaillantes advent 6 à seattle en fait
en retardant le début des cours de 50
minutes le temps de sommeil des élèves a
augmenté de 34 minutes et leurs notes
ont progressé voilà c'est le résultat de
cette étude aurait dit gourgeon pourquoi
c'est important de bien dormir quand on
est lycéen
alors tout d'abord il faut rappeler que
lorsqu'on est adolescent la médecine les
médecins préconisent de dormir entre 8
et 10 heures
on constate qu'il y a à peu près 13 %
des lits siens qui dorment plus de huit
heures
la majorité ne dort qu'entre quatre et
six heures donc on avait un vrai
problème du temps de sommeil chez les
adolescents et alors le sommeil est
important pour plusieurs raisons la
première c'est que il faut quand même se
reposer un moment reposer un peu le
corps ça favorise la même la
mémorisation
ça favorise la concentration en cours et
ça permet aussi la sécrétion de
plusieurs hormones qui sont
indispensables dans l'âge enfin pour le
fonctionnement de notre corps l'ars a
fait le buzz comment se comportent les
lycéens le matin en cour à ce qu'ils
sont en mode zombie j'ai envie de dire
ou alors est ce qu'ils sont attentifs
le matin forcément ils sont plutôt
fatigué mais de toute manière c'est pas
ça ne sera pas en reculant d'une heure
que les choses changeront ils vont juste
se coucher plus tard et cette étude
j'avais mieux quelques quelques contres
enfin quelques arguments contre elle a
été menée sur sept mois donc oui on a
une augmentation des notes des résultats
mais est ce que c'est vraiment probant
je ne sais pas
or l ego gens que vous avez parlé en
tout à l'heure du rythme biologique donc
des lycéens qui étaient différents des
adultes
vous l'avez du tout à l'heure ils ont
besoin les lycéens de dormir entre 8h et
10h du coup ce qu'il ressort de votre
étude de la smerep en fait c'est que les
lycéens finalement mondor moins que huit
heures comment comme vous avez procédé
en fait à cette étude
alors pour mener cette enquête nous
avons donc réalisé en partenariat avec
opinionway auprès de 1000 lycéens sur
toute la france avec une répartition
entre les différentes régions
tout comme il ya plus de liste ee en ile
de france il était représenté en pro en
faisant ces proportions et le on leur a
posé simplement la question de combien
de temps dormez-vous par nuit en moyenne
pendant la semaine mais également
pendant le week end et donc les
propositions étaient moins de 6 heures
en moins de quatre heures entre 4 et 6
heures entre 6 et 8 heures et plus de
huit heures et la majorité dorment 75 %
des lycéens dorment entre six et huit
heures par nuit donc bien en-deça de ce
qui serait préconisé et c'était des
différences entre les filières
généralistes par exemple ou les filières
professionnelles ou ceux qui se font ça
après un bep ce que alors il y à
quelques différences
les différences ne sont pas
significatives pour autant n'est on
remarque par exemple dans les bacs
technologiques les étudiants dorment
moins de cibles plus d'étudiants dans
moins de six heures que les gens les
élèves en filière générale et il y
aurait potentiellement un lien avec une
autre question que l'on a posé cette
année dans notre enquête qui était
l'utilisation des smartphones et des
écrans au cours de la journée et là où
en filière générale
ils sont 26% a passé plus de quatre
heures sur leur téléphone entre deux
quatre heures sur leur téléphone par
jour il 13% excusez moi il passe à 26 %
lorsqu'ils sont en filières techniques
et lorsque l'on sait que l'utilisation
des écrans le soir avant de dormir à
cause de la lumière bleue et du côté
addictif que peut présenter internet et
les réseaux sociaux empêchent les prend
le pas sur un an de l'endormissement il
y ait un lien avec le retard du moment
de l'endormissement et donc des nippes
courte parce qu'il faut toujours se
lever le lendemain matin pour aller en
cours les rafales de golf j'imagine que
vous le constatez vous peut-être même je
sais pas dans nos salles de cours
l'utilisation des smartphones depuis ces
dernières années par les élèves
oui et justement ça pose la question est
ce que c'est vraiment le fait de changer
l'horaire qui va changer le comportement
des élèves
si c'est pas plutôt le smartphone de
toute manière ils se coucheront toujours
plus tard après ses jeux restent
toujours très étonné par cette cette
proposition ce que c'est on voit bien
que c'est quand même une proposition qui
coûte rien adam pécresse et nous on
aimerait plutôt qu'elle nous fasse des
propositions pour remettre mettre plus
d'argent pour remettre en état les
lycées parce que quand on a des
bâtiments où il pleut à l'intérieur
qu'on n'a pas de chauffage qui fait 13
degrés qui commence à 8 heures à 9
heures les élèves auront toujours froid
ainsi que le personnel
alors on a posé la question aux dubina
pour savoir un petit peu ce qu'ils
pensaient de cette annonce avoir
justement si c'était une bonne idée que
de commencer donc les cours des lycéens
plus tard regardez la plupart ont
beaucoup de temps de transport le matin
mon frère par exemple qui est encore au
lycée à 1h30 de transport donc il se
lève vers 6 heures du matin et ça fait
ça fait trop se fait pas assez d'heures
de sommeil parce qu'en parallèle faut
qu'il travaille le soir jusque tard donc
je pense que ce serait une bonne idée
mais je trouve le matin et mieux
concentrée que le soir ont commencé tous
les jours à 8 heures et je trouve que
c'était bien parce que quand tu te
réveilles le matin tu as plus d'énergie
pour pour apprendre les leçons
à mon avis je pense pas que une heure
après ça va changer grand-chose faut se
lever on se lève et tu vas pas mourir si
tu te lèves et nord plutôt quoi c'est
rien du tout le monde l'a fait lève-toi
et demain quand tu vas travailler tu vas
commencer plus tôt donc à butoir de
maman d'un côté on peut les laisser ce
qu'un peu plus en forme le matin
mais en fait c'est l'inconvénient c'est
que du coup ils termineraient plus tard
les cours et rentraient au final ils
vont rentrer plus tard chez eux le soir
et auront moins de temps pour faire
leurs devoirs et pour faire d'autres
choses moi personnellement je préfère
commencer plus tôt et terminer plus tôt
dans l'après midi pour être avoir plus
de temps chez moi et faire mes devoirs à
tout ça voilà vous l'avez vu à vis
plutôt mitigé inde et des yvelines mois
qu'on a qu'on a interrogé un fail le
goff
il y avait la question des devoirs est
ce que finalement aussi les journées
sont pas trop denses au lycée est ce
qu'il n'ya pas trop de devoirs justement
à faire c'est chaque professeur vous
dira aura son avis trop de devoirs
non je ne pense pas nous ce qu'on veut
c'est travailler avec nos élèves au
lycée et sur cette organisation du temps
de toute manière ça ne se fera pas sans
l'avis du personnel s'il faudrait pas
aller j'ai peut-être les programmes
réorganiser un petit peu les journées je
vais parler pour le lycée professionnel
au vu de la réforme qui nous arrivent
pour la rentrée 2010 9
les programmes seront assez allégé pour
qu'il soit tranquille et je sais pas
forcément une bonne chose pour nos
élèves alors et les gorges de cette
étude que vous menez sur sur le sommeil
des lices à vous la faites depuis un peu
plus de dix ans il me semble est ce que
vous avez observé un changement une
évolution justement sur le sommeil ces
dernières années alors oui c'est une
question qu'on a posés depuis les tout
débuts l'enquète en 2009 est donc
toujours la même question combien de
temps dormez-vous dans une nuit et à
l'époque il était 11 3 % des étudiants à
dormir moins de six heures et maintenant
on passe en 2018 à 21%
donc on a une augmentation qui n'est pas
non plus catastrophique mais je pense
que pour un élève qui doit dans l'indre
8 et 10 heures commençait à avoir un
quart de la population étudiante qui
dort que moins de six heures il ya un
commence à avoir un vrai problème alors
un des arguments mis en avant également
par les spécialistes le fait de
commencer plus tard ce serait de lutter
contre l'absentéisme scolaire est ce que
vous seriez d'accord afin de le goff
avec cette idée je pense pas que ce soit
vraiment je pense
vraiment pas que ce soit le fait de
commencer plus tard qui va enlever enfin
qui va lutter contre l'absentéisme
parce que à 9 heures ils pourront
toujours être autant absent est en tout
cas aux dernières heures entre 17h30 et
18h30
ce que nous ont commencé à 8h30 en
terminale 17h25 si on commence à 9h30 on
terminera forcément 18h30 les élèves
partiront c'est pareil il revient enfin
je suis aux mureaux ils viennent de man
qui viennent d'epône il ya des trains
des bus
c'est toute une organisation à revoir et
ça changera strictement rien une
question sur la prévention est ce que
justement la smerep mène des actions de
prévention pour sûr sur le sommeil
justement d'aider des lycéens sur la
prévention ne pas utiliser le smartphone
par exemple avant de s'endormir
exactement ça fait partie des axes de
prévention qu'on développe depuis
plusieurs années qu'on a entièrement
revu pour la rentrée en janvier 2019
et oui alors on fait majoritairement
pour l'instant auprès des étudiants
parce que pour nous c'était plus facile
de rentrer dans les universités mais
maintenant on a des accords avec des
lycées pour pouvoir faire ces mêmes
thématiques succès même thématique de
prévention est donc sur le sommeil c'est
surtout sous forme de jeu toujours parce
que ce sont des jeunes qui s'adressent à
d'autres jeunes on veut pas être mollard
moralisateur et on veut faire passer un
message qu'ils soient qu'ils soient
bienveillant auprès des jeunes
voilà tous ces tous déjà couché tard ça
peut arriver de le faire mais il faut
pas que ça devienne une habitude et on
leur fait prend aussi de leur faire
prendre conscience de l'importance du
sommeil et donc de l'importance d'aller
se coucher sans un téléphone arrêtés à
leur téléphone ou en tout cas tout écran
au moins une heure avant et de mettre en
place une forme de routine dans la
soirée avec un coucher qui soit reposant
où on ait l'impression de ce complément
de se déconnecter de la journée qu'on
l'on vient de passer parce qu'il est
aussi un autre phénomène qui engendre
des routes et trouble de
l'endormissement c'est le stress qui
quand même également présent chez les
lycéens
faut pas penser que parce qu'ils sont
jeunes ne sont pas stressés notamment à
cause des études parce qu'ils ne savent
pas parce que sera leur avenir
l'orientation et tout ça et donc c'est
important de se créer une bulle avant
d'aller s'endormir pour pouvoir passer
une bonne nuit donc finalement plus de
prévention peut-être justement
objet de retarder les heures des cours
trente secondes raphaël le goff pour
pour conclure donc bonne idée ou fausse
bonne idée de retarder les cours des
lycées ans selon vous nous on veut des
moyens pour les lycées mais pour les
bâtiments de la part de la région et je
suis contente qu'il y ait des des études
pour les élèves mais moi j'aimerais bien
des études pour la santé du personnel
aussi parce que quand on rentre chez
nous on a aussi le droit à la
déconnexion
ce qui n'est pas fait et c'est
d'ailleurs une revendication dans
comment s'appelle dans nos luttes avec
les enseignants contre l'envahissement
du travail à la maison et la
rémunération a juste juste pour tout ce
travail qui est fait à la maison et non
face élèves
on a cette émission touche à sa fin
merci en tout cas toutes les deux
d'avoir répondu présentes pour ce débat
on se retrouve bien sûr mercredi
prochain pour un nouveau séduit le débat
[Musique]